the girag an experience
[Music]
Oh
demons be gone be gone demons be gone
leave this studio leave this planet
leave our universe leave this is legit
sage from a Native American woman Wow
so we're purifying strong wonderful owe
you money but may owe money but may you
please God bless this room and Odin to
you just in case they were wrong that
Ty's abandoned Odin he was around first
you know you got to think of all the
gods that everybody believed in and
they're like I'm not so sure about Thor
yeah and then they let him go what if
Thor was legit right and he's still out
there just like somebody who just pissed
a lot of Fame as a god yeah he's like
don't you [ __ ] see the Lightning yeah
that's me throwing bolts he's like one
of those guys and you go to Vegas and
you see one of those billboards for a
strange casino and you're like oh that
guy yeah
Tony Orlando and Dawn I remember them
Thor is it the Mirage of course doing a
residency your [ __ ] check out
the Thunder that's actually caused by
atmospheric conditions no you [ __ ]
doors on cameo make that imagine who had
a someone had a really good point about
that some some atheists was arguing
against religions it might have been sam
harris probably sam harris but might
even richard dawkins but he basically
said there's 99 different gods that
people who believe in the Christian God
don't believe it and he goes atheist
just take it one step further hey we
just one got away that's what he was
saying that's cool
yeah there I get confused with being an
atheist all the time I don't I do not
believe I'm an atheist I I believe I am
I'm open to everything person I don't
believe stories about people coming back
from
dad you know because they're written by
people right yeah man I mean that's
right and also they're supposed to
function on more than the surface level
they're supposed to be a kind of fractal
that has inside of it a lot of like
symbols related to just human existence
yes not they're not meant to be so much
like taken literally that's when you
embarrass yourself on either side
exactly on either side of you that's a
really good point it's in the
translations apparently are so difficult
to do yeah apparently the trail
especially Old Testament when they
translated the Old Testament they had to
translate it didn't think of all the
different languages it had to go through
it was Latin and Greek and German and
English and all these different
languages that are so different like if
you ever used the the translate button
like I follow a lot of Russian fighters
and they you know and their Instagram
feed they write in Russian I'm always
like oh translate it's a really cool
feature you could but you could tell
it's not exactly what they meant because
it's all [ __ ] up because their
language is different right like the way
they structure sentences is different so
English doesn't just plug and play right
you know it's like sticking a USB 3 into
a USB a hey this doesn't really fit all
right now add time add thousands of
years and scrolls and my hangs wanted
things changed yeah the King James
Version it's the best that's my favorite
one to read on acid that's one King
James book a John baby hit that on acid
it's so wonderful it's so trippy because
it's like that's when I really like
Christianity clicked for me regardless
of its whether it's real or not but
that's when I was like okay I get this
because the book of John when you read
it you're like well someone wrote it I
don't know who wrote it and you ever
[ __ ] wrote this their mind was blown
man like this wasn't written by someone
who was just like a normal person this
is the person who was freaking out in
the most intense way and so to me that's
what I love about it is it's like
something about the how old it is and
the distortions the historical
distortions the warping of it produce
this kind of awesome glitched out
mosaic of if nothing else human
consciousness 5,000 years ago where our
minds were that's trippy by itself
regardless of whether or not a person
who could like raise the dead and walk
on water what's walking about just
wholly sit here's how people thought bad
yes yes yeah I mean all the stuff that
you can't prove you don't know that's
interesting it's weird it's weird that
where those stories came from and why
they're so universal like someone has to
everyone has like a creator everyone has
like a main dude that did the thing and
you know then there's some other people
that have like large groups of gods like
the Greeks had gods for everything
the Indonesian ativ Americans had gods
for everything or yeah
[Applause]